From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass. Ira is here, but I'm taking over today's show because we're talking about questions that I think are pretty fundamental to all of us at various points in our lives but are especially pressing for me these days. I'd like to explain with a brief example of a situation I find myself in all the time lately, with my two children, feeling deeply lost.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。Ira其实就在现场，但今天由我来接管节目，因为我们正在讨论一些我认为在人生各个阶段对我们每个人都至关重要，但最近对我而言尤为紧迫的问题。我想通过一个我最近常遇到的、让我感到极其迷茫的、关于我两个孩子的例子来解释这一点。
It's bath time. Jacob, the older one, is running a restaurant. He's giving out great prizes-- cups for grownups, and also animals.
现在是洗澡时间。大一点的儿子Jacob在开一家餐馆。他正在发放很棒的奖品——大人的杯子，还有动物玩偶。
Animals.
动物。
I want to hug an animal.
我想抱抱那个动物。
Jacob says, if someone in your family is Christian, you can get one of those.
Jacob说，如果你家里有人是基督徒，你就可以拿一个。
But if somebody in your family is Christian, you're going to give those to them.
但是如果有人是基督徒，你就要把那些给他们。
What?
什么？
Is your family Christian?
你们家是基督徒吗？
No.
不是。
Is your mom or your dad Christian?
你妈妈或爸爸是基督徒吗？
No.
不是。
Is your brother or your sister Christian?
你哥哥或姐姐是基督徒吗？
No. They're all Jewish.
不是。他们都是犹太人。
He snatches the animal and says, sorry.
他一把抢过动物，说，抱歉。
Wait. I can't have any animals unless I'm Christian?
等等。除非我是基督徒，否则我就不能拿任何动物吗？
You can't have that duck, sorry.
你不能拿那只鸭子，抱歉。
Why can't I have the duck?
为什么我不能拿那只鸭子？
Because you're not Christian.
因为你不是基督徒。
No Jews allowed, says my 3 and 1/2-year-old to my Jewish face. So here is my question-- what am I supposed to say right here? Because I should say something, right? I should say, that is not OK, because-- why?
“不准犹太人入内”，我3岁半的儿子对着我这张犹太人的脸说道。那么问题来了——我这时候该说什么？因为我得说点什么，对吧？我应该说，那是不对的，因为——为什么呢？
Because I said so? Because you're a Jew? Because Jews like your great grandparents were driven from their communities by exactly the mentality you've just expressed to me, my 3 and 1/2-year-old boy? Or because we live in a majority Christian country, and I'm worried that I've clearly already failed to provide you with a positive relationship to Judaism?
因为我说了算吗？因为你是犹太人吗？因为犹太人（比如你的曾祖父母）正是被你刚才对我——你3岁半的儿子——所表达的那种心态赶出了社区？还是因为我们生活在一个以基督教为主的国家，我担心我显然已经没能让你与犹太教建立起积极的关系？
Or is the best approach not to say anything? He's just having a bath. I don't know, as you will hear.
还是说最好的做法就是什么都不说？他只是在洗澡。我不知道，你会听到的。
But sweetie, it's not nice to say that somebody can't have something because they're not Christian.
但是宝贝，说别人因为不是基督徒就不能拿东西，这样是不礼貌的。
Well, you can't have the animals because you're not Christian.
嗯，你不能拿这些动物，因为你不是基督徒。
That makes me feel sad, though, sweetie.
但那让我感到难过，宝贝。
Well, many people who are Christian can have those animals. In this restaurant, that's what the rules are.
嗯，许多基督徒可以拥有那些动物。在这个餐馆里，这就是规则。
That's not kind, though.
但那不友善。
Yeah, but that's what the rules are at this restaurant.
是的，但这就是这家餐馆的规则。
Well, there's so many rules in this anti-Semitic restaurant.
好吧，这家反犹太餐馆里的规矩可真多。
Sorry. They're kind for some people.
抱歉。它们对某些人是友善的。
He says, they're kind for some people, just not my kind of people. The problem with talking to kids about anything that's actually important is that they don't know anything. It's your job to teach them about all of the stuff that matters most, but you have nothing to work with.
他说，它们对某些人是友善的，只是不对我这类人友善。和孩子们谈论真正重要的事情时，问题在于他们什么都不懂。你的工作是教他们所有最重要的事情，但你却没有什么素材可用。
They don't know religion. They don't know history. They don't know how to maintain proper hygiene.
他们不懂宗教。他们不懂历史。他们不知道如何保持正确的个人卫生。
Also a problem, they're little, and they have feelings. So you have to be careful about saying, well, let me tell you a story about a man named Adolf Hitler. He would have liked the way you run your restaurant, by the way.
还有一个问题，他们年纪很小，而且有情感。所以你得小心，不能说，好吧，让我给你讲一个关于阿道夫·希特勒的男人的故事。顺便说一句，他会很喜欢你经营餐馆的方式。
We've all been on the kid side of this kind of conversation, where a grownup is fumbling through something that is clearly important. The big one most of us remember is when someone told us about sex. And on the adult side, whatever the question is-- what is sex, what is God, or what is ISIS, what does transgendered mean-- you know in that moment that what you say could really matter, could be the thing this person remembers and carries with them into adulthood, could shape the way they feel about their safety or their sexuality. These conversations are how we make our mark on the next generation. They're also, very often, how we learn how much we do not know.
我们都曾作为孩子经历过这种对话，当时一个成年人在笨拙地处理某件明显很重要的事情。我们大多数人记得最清楚的一件大事是有人告诉我们关于性的事。而在成年人这边，无论问题是什么——什么是性，什么是上帝，或者什么是ISIS，变性意味着什么——在那一刻你知道你所说的话真的很重要，可能会成为这个人记住并带入成年生活的东西，可能会影响他们对自身安全或性的感受。这些对话是我们给下一代打上烙印的方式。它们也经常是我们学习到自己有多么无知的方式。
And in today's show, we're going to listen in as people take on three of the most difficult things to talk about. We're going to hear teenagers talking very frankly to each other about sex, parents talking to their children about race, and kids talking to each other about death. Today's show, "The Birds and the Bees." We've got Jonathan Goldstein, comedian W. Kamau Bell. Stay with us.
在今天的节目中，我们将聆听人们如何面对三个最难谈论的话题。我们将听到青少年非常坦率地谈论性，父母与孩子谈论种族，以及孩子们谈论死亡。今天的节目是《鸟儿与蜜蜂》。嘉宾有Jonathan Goldstein和喜剧演员W. Kamau Bell。请继续收听。
Act One, "Some Like It Not, On the Neck." To begin, I should say, throughout this hour we're going to be talking about subject matter that can be difficult to discuss with children. So if you've got kids listening, that's something to consider. Also in this next story, as Ira says, we will be acknowledging the existence of sex and talking a lot about our reluctance to speak of its existence.
第一幕，《有些人不喜欢，在脖子上》。首先，我应该说明，在接下来的一小时里，我们将讨论一些难以与孩子沟通的主题。所以如果你有孩子在听，这是需要考虑的。同样在下一个故事里，正如Ira所说，我们将承认性的存在，并谈论我们对谈论其存在的抵触。
OK, let's start with the beginning. One way a lot of kids learn about the birds and bees is from each other. A couple weeks ago, a seven-year-old named Moxie told me a friend of hers, this kid, Aaron, said something to her that bothered her on the bus. He said, if he drew a picture of a baby on a piece of paper and put it in her belly, that would make a baby.
好的，我们从头开始。很多孩子了解“鸟儿与蜜蜂”的方式是通过彼此。几周前，一个叫Moxie的七岁女孩告诉我，她的朋友Aaron在校车上对她说了一些困扰她的话。他说，如果他在纸上画一个婴儿，然后把它放进她的肚子里，那就会生出一个婴儿。
Moxie knew this was incorrect. That's why it bothered her. So a week later at the playground across the street from her house, she sat Aaron down.
Moxie知道这是不对的。这就是为什么她感到困扰。所以一周后，在她家对面的操场上，她让Aaron坐下来。
The situation about the paper not working thing.
关于那张纸不管用的情况。
What's that means?
那是什么意思？
On the bus a few days ago, you talked about paper and body and about a baby.
几天前在校车上，你谈到了纸和身体，还有关于婴儿的事。
Oh, right, right, right.
哦，对，对，对。
That was a silly plan.
那是个愚蠢的计划。
I'm sure it's going to work, but I don't know.
我确定它会成功的，但我不知道。
Uh, I'm not sure, because the baby can't survive, you see? I'm just saying.
呃，我不确定，因为婴儿无法存活，你明白吗？我只是随口一说。
Sorry.
抱歉。
You need to make a sperm. And the sperm somehow has to get into my body. And that's how it works.
你需要制造精子。精子必须以某种方式进入我的身体。这就是它的运作方式。
I did not know that.
我不知道这一点。
Well, now you do.
好吧，现在你知道了。
Sorry.
抱歉。
When it comes to sex, a lot of us learn the wrong thing first and the right thing later. You learn through a series of corrections. You start to find out that half the things your brother told you were not right, that that scene in the movie is not realistic, that [? Sophia De Santos ?] was lying when she said she did that thing, because that thing is not possible.
当谈到性时，我们很多人先学到了错误的东西，后来才学到正确的。你是通过一系列的纠正来学习的。你开始发现你哥哥告诉你的事情有一半是不对的，电影里的那一幕并不现实，[Sophia De Santos]说她做了那件事是在撒谎，因为那件事根本不可能发生。
That's basically our system. You learn things wrong, test them out, and hopefully get the real story from someone named Moxie. This begins on the playground and just continues all the way until you actually start having sex, and all the weird information that was not corrected begins to matter.
这基本上就是我们的系统。你学到了错误的东西，去尝试它们，希望从一个叫Moxie的人那里得到真实的故事。这始于操场，一直持续到你真正开始发生性关系，而所有那些未经纠正的怪异信息开始变得重要为止。
What are you hoping they're going to cover?
你希望他们涵盖什么内容？
I hope they cover everything.
我希望他们涵盖所有内容。
Deondre is in a classroom at Buffalo State with about 50 other people, mostly men, mostly his fraternity brothers. He's here for some sex ed.
Deondre在布法罗州立大学的一间教室里，周围大约有50人，大多数是男性，大多数是他的兄弟会成员。他来这里是为了接受一些性教育。
I feel like some stuff people don't know.
我觉得有些东西人们不知道。
What don't you know?
你不知道什么？
I don't know. That's a good question, you know.
我不知道。这是个好问题，你知道的。
This is a voluntary workshop about sexual assault and consent, on a Monday night. You'd think this event might not win out over, say, hitting up the Jamba Juice or staring at your van Gogh poster.
这是一个关于性侵犯和同意的自愿研讨会，在周一晚上。你可能会觉得这个活动比去喝果汁或者盯着你的梵高海报更有吸引力。
But this room is packed. The students are wide awake. Knees are bouncing. Hands are shooting up in the air. The instructor, Paula Madrigal, is talking about the importance of consent.
但这个房间挤满了人。学生们都很清醒。膝盖在抖动。手纷纷举起。讲师Paula Madrigal正在谈论同意的重要性。
So consent is a verbal and enthusiastic yes, OK? Why is it enthusiastic?
所以，同意是一个口头的、热情的“是”，好吗？为什么要是热情的？
Because you actually want to do it.
因为你真的想做。
Exactly. You want to do it. And sex should be fun, right?
完全正确。你真的想做。而且性应该是快乐的，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. I hope so.
是的。我希望如此。
This kind of workshop was repeated in classrooms all across campus here and throughout the country in the last year. College administrators are panicked about sexual assault, as they should be. So they're turning to this kind of education as the answer instead of mostly focusing on protecting women, things like rape whistles or travel with a buddy programs.
过去一年里，这种研讨会在全国各地的校园教室里反复进行。大学管理者对性侵犯感到恐慌，他们理应如此。所以他们转向这种教育作为答案，而不是主要专注于保护女性，比如防狼哨或结伴同行计划。
They also want to teach men actual sentences to say. Do you like this? Can I kiss you? But the students here are struggling with the basic premise.
他们还想教男学生实际要说的话。你喜欢这样吗？我可以吻你吗？但这里的学生们正在努力理解这个基本前提。
They have to learn to speak in this new way because if you don't you're a rapist? Because it's just more virtuous? They have questions right from the start.
他们必须学习用这种新方式说话，因为如果你不这样做，你就是强奸犯？因为这只是更高尚？他们从一开始就有疑问。
It's a continuous process of checking up, or checking in, either/or. What does that mean?
这是一个持续的检查过程，或者说确认过程，两者皆有。那是什么意思？
You keep asking her? That's weird.
你一直问她？那太怪了。
That kind of messes up the mood. I'm not trying to be funny, but if she says yes, and you know, she keeps saying, yeah, I've got to be like, hey, you sure? Are you really sure? We're about to do this.
那样会破坏气氛。我不是想搞笑，但如果她说好，而且你知道，她一直说，好，我得像这样，嘿，你确定吗？你真的确定吗？我们要开始做了。
Every 10 minutes.
每10分钟一次。
I'm almost there. I'm about to go to the drawer to get the protection. No, no. You're right. You're right. You're right.
我快到了。我正要走到抽屉去拿避孕套。不，不。你是对的。你是对的。你是对的。
And you're like, no.
然后你就像，不。
No. Obviously, I'm going to stop. But the re-affirmation of yes over and over again, that kind of would mess up the mood. So I feel like should there be a number of times that you should-- you know?
不。显然，我会停下来。但反复的“同意”再确认，那样会破坏气氛。所以我感觉，是不是应该有一个次数限制……你知道吗？
He presses them on this. Two? Three? Seven? But that guy is overtaken by his fraternity brothers, who also have urgent questions. Does body language count as consent?
他在此事上追问他们。两次？三次？七次？但那个家伙被他的兄弟会成员抢了话，他们也有紧急的问题。肢体语言算作同意吗？
What if she said yes before you got into the room when you were both sober, like in a message on Twitter or something? How many beers is too much to have consent? Again, please offer a number.
如果她在你进入房间前你们都清醒的时候说了好呢，比如在推特上发消息之类的？喝多少啤酒算是不清醒而不能同意？再次请给出一个数字。
Like, you ever heard the term alcohol is liquid courage? Like, what if it's in the sense where it's like you were probably nervous, and you don't want to be nervous around her. So that's your liquid courage. All right, I'm not going to be shaky when she come over. You feel me? So you're not using it to get a yes.
比如，你听过“酒精是液态勇气”这个词吗？比如，如果它是那种情况，你可能很紧张，而你不想在她面前紧张。所以那是你的液态勇气。好吧，她过来时我就不会手抖了。你明白我的意思吗？所以你不是为了获得许可而利用它。
The next guy over interrupts. What if both parties are drunk? And then across the room-- does the girl need to ask for consent? Another student-- OK, what if we've been together for a year?
旁边的人插话。如果双方都喝醉了怎么办？然后房间对面有人问——女孩需要征求同意吗？另一个学生问——好吧，如果我们要在一起一年了怎么办？
Paula Madrigal replies, you always need consent, even if you're a woman, even if you're a man sleeping with men, even if you're in a relationship, even if you have sex every day, even if you are in the middle sex.
Paula Madrigal回答说，你总是需要同意，即使你是女性，即使你是与男性发生性关系的男性，即使你在一段关系中，即使你们每天都发生性关系，即使你处于中性。
Or if you guys are engaging in sexual activity, and maybe all of a sudden someone decides I want to try it rough, if you guys already started having sex, the other person can withdraw that consent. OK? So that's why it's active.
或者如果你们正在进行性活动，也许突然有人决定我想尝试狂野一点，如果你们已经开始发生性关系，另一个人可以撤销那个同意。好吗？这就是为什么它是主动的。
What if someone's like, I want to have another person here, now let's have three people? You're already having sex. So if all of a sudden they're like, surprise, I have another person, you can be like, yeah, um, I didn't really sign up for that. I'm out of here. OK? Does that make a little bit more sense when we talk about, you know, checking in and the active process?
如果有人说，我想让另一个人在这里，现在我们三个人一起做？你们已经开始发生性关系了。所以如果突然他们说，惊喜，我有另一个人，你可以说，是的，嗯，我没签下那样的合同。我走了。好吗？当我们谈论检查和主动过程时，这听起来更有意义一点吗？
Those are carefully chosen examples. The vast majority of sexual assault on college campuses occur between two people who know each other. And there's not always physical force.
这些都是精心挑选的例子。大学校园里绝大多数性侵犯发生在彼此认识的两个人之间。并不总是存在肢体暴力。
So Paula is trying to say, take the picture you have in your mind of a serial predator rapist. Put it to the side for a moment. Imagine instead a person who wakes up in the morning and wonders quietly to himself, she was into that, right? Yeah, she was into that. Imagine that person is wrong.
所以Paula试图说，把你脑海中那个连环性掠夺者的画像放到一边。想象一下一个早上醒来默默对自己说的人：她很享受那个，对吧？是的，她很享受那个。想象一下那个人错了。
The workshop was supposed to be 45 minutes. It's been an hour. Paula Madrigal is trying to wrap up.
研讨会原本计划45分钟。已经过去一小时了。Paula Madrigal试图总结。
So how do you guys, then-- you guys are the experts. How do you ask for consent?
那么你们这些家伙，你们是专家，你们如何征求同意？
It doesn't sound right. It's like you're messing up the whole mood when you ask that.
听起来不对劲。就好像当你问那个问题时，你破坏了整个气氛。
It's been an hour, and the students in this room are still fixated on this question of the mood. I don't remember there being a whole lot of mood when it came to sex in college. I don't know, maybe you guys all had candle-lit dorm rooms.
已经一小时了，这个房间里的学生仍然纠结于这个“气氛”的问题。我不记得我在大学发生性关系时有过什么气氛。我不知道，也许你们都有烛光宿舍。
But there is genuine panic behind that question. It's dismissed in a workshop about sexual assault, because of course it is. We're taking about assault. You're talking about the mood. Those are two separate conversations.
但那个问题背后有真正的恐慌。在关于性侵犯的研讨会上它被忽视了，因为当然会被忽视。我们在谈论侵犯。你在谈论气氛。那是两个独立的对话。
But these guys are trying to have just one conversation about everything, a conversation that takes into account consent, but also all of their questions and anxieties when it comes to talking to a person they're sleeping with. It seems like that's a conversation they've never had.
但这些家伙试图只进行一个关于所有事情的对话，一个既考虑同意，又考虑他们与性伴侣交谈时所有问题和焦虑的对话。看起来那是他们从未进行过的对话。
That is one of the hardest things ever, is to try to find out-- how would you say find out what the other person wants?
那是史上最困难的事情之一，试着弄清楚——你会怎么说去弄清楚对方想要什么？
This is the Nagib Gonzalez, a college freshman in Buffalo. I known Nagib from previous reporting. He's lovely. And like every freshman at his school, he's been to a consent training in the last year.
这是Nagib Gonzalez，布法罗的一名大学新生。我从以前的报道中认识Nagib。他很可爱。而且像他学校的每个新生一样，他在过去一年里参加过一次同意培训。
I feel like if we're going to lay the burden of changing the way we talk about sex at the feet of 18-year-olds, people who are already many years into learning weird and bad and confusing information, if that's our answer to reduce sexual assault, I wanted to know more about what these guys actually know and where they learned it.
我觉得如果我们要把改变我们谈论性方式的重担放在18岁年轻人的肩上，这些人已经多年来在学习奇怪、糟糕且令人困惑的信息，如果这就是我们减少性侵犯的答案，我想更多地了解这些家伙实际上知道什么，以及他们是从哪里学到的。
Men talk about women all the time. I just thought, like, my roommate always talks to me about his favorite sex position. And then my other friends would tell me their favorite sex positions, and then we'll just talk about, oh, that's cool. Oh, I'll try that one one day.
男人们一直在谈论女性。我只是想，比如，我的室友总是跟我谈论他最喜欢的性姿势。然后我的其他朋友会告诉我他们最喜欢的性姿势，然后我们会谈论，哦，那很酷。哦，我改天试试那个。
But that's men who are sleeping with women talking about what women like to other men.
但那是与女性发生性关系的男性在向其他男性谈论女性喜欢什么。
Yeah. So it's more like we'll decide what women do or don't like.
是的。所以更多像是我们决定女性喜欢或不喜欢什么。
But when do you talk to women about what they like?
但你什么时候和女性谈论她们喜欢什么？
Hmm. Yeah, OK, it's definitely men talk to men about what women like. I feel like that's how it is. Even if you get told by a woman what she likes, you'll be like, oh, I knew that.
嗯。是的，好吧，绝对是男性向男性谈论女性喜欢什么。我觉得就是那样。即使有个女人告诉你她喜欢什么，你也会觉得，哦，我早就知道了。
Lately Nagib's biggest source of information is his roommate, Elijah Leslie. He brought Elijah up a lot. Elijah says he first learned about the birds and bees from his cousin.
最近Nagib最大的信息来源是他的室友Elijah Leslie。他经常提起Elijah。Elijah说他第一次从表哥那里了解到鸟儿与蜜蜂的事。
Then you get older. Then you see Sports Illustrated . Then you see the Playboy s. Then you see the porn. And then you see the Girls Gone Wild . Then you see those late night-- the Girls Gone Wild, the late night commercials and stuff like that. Like 4:00 in the morning, Girls Gone Wild. I think that's when you start learning.
然后你长大。然后你看到《体育画报》。然后你看到《花花公子》。然后你看到色情片。然后你看到《Girls Gone Wild》。然后你看到那些深夜——《Girls Gone Wild》，深夜广告之类的东西。就像凌晨4点，Girls Gone Wild。我想那就是你开始学习的时候。
Elijah was not the first or the last person I interviewed who told me he learned about sex from porn. So Nagib is learning how to engage with women from other men who are learning from porn. That's like learning Chinese from a white American in Wyoming. You're missing some key primary source information.
Elijah不是我采访的第一个也不是最后一个告诉我他从色情片里学到性知识的人。所以Nagib正在从其他从色情片中学习的男性那里学习如何与女性互动。这就像向怀俄明州的美国白人学习中文一样。你错过了一些关键的一手信息。
Every person I talk to who works on sexual assault prevention brought up one thing as particularly troubling about the way men learn about sex, and it wasn't porn. It was baseball, that we talk about sex like it's baseball, getting a home run as a metaphor for sex. They said, think of how many bad lessons are built into that metaphor. You go first base, second base, third base. There's only one direction to move. And a home run is a win.
每一个我交谈过的从事性侵犯预防工作的人都提到了一件关于男性学习性知识方式特别令人担忧的事情，那不是色情片。是棒球，我们谈论性就像谈论棒球一样，把打出本垒打作为性的隐喻。他们说，想想那个隐喻中包含了多少错误的教训。你从一垒、二垒、三垒。只有一个方向可以移动。而本垒打是一场胜利。
Not to mention, you're on opposing teams. It's competitive. And it's a sport that mostly only men play.
更不用说，你们在对立的队伍中。这是竞争性的。而且这是一项主要只有男性参与的运动。
Nagib Gonzalez is not attached to sex being like baseball or porn. Nagib just wants to be a good person. He wants to be good to people. He's looking for some guidance. Nagib is always looking for guidance. He solicits advice often.
Nagib Gonzalez并不觉得性像棒球或色情片。Nagib只想做一个好人。他想对别人好。他在寻找一些指导。Nagib总是在寻找指导。他经常寻求建议。
This is an example. I remember my cousin telling me, yo, you've got to kiss your girl's neck. I do it all the time. Oh, my girl loves it, and stuff like that. So then that's kind of where you learn.
这是一个例子。我记得我表哥告诉我，嘿，你得吻你女孩的脖子。我经常这样做。哦，我的女孩很喜欢它，之类的话。所以那基本上就是你学习的地方。
Nagib, ever the careful student, kissed necks, every one of them. Another friend told him, women like it when you're funny. He tries to be that.
Nagib，一直是个认真的学生，吻过脖子，每一个。另一个朋友告诉他，女性喜欢你幽默。他努力做到这一点。
But then, Nagib had a girlfriend who told everybody he was a bad kisser. And someone told him, please stop kissing my neck. She thought it was gross. And he felt like, wait, do I know things? Or do I not know things?
但后来，Nagib有一个女朋友告诉所有人他是个糟糕的接吻者。有人告诉他，请停止亲吻我的脖子。她觉得那很恶心。他觉得，等等，我知道东西吗？还是我什么都不知道？
Definitely when you're younger, you think of it more as rules and steps to get laid. When you're younger, you think, oh, I have to do this step. I have to follow these steps. So I have to kiss her in this certain place. Then I have to make out with her.
绝对当你年轻的时候，你更多地把它看作是获得性关系的规则和步骤。当你年轻的时候，你想，哦，我必须做这一步。我必须遵循这些步骤。所以我必须在那个特定的地方吻她。然后我必须和她亲热。
Then I have to-- I don't know-- touch her. I don't know. I don't know, grab her butt or something. And then, finally we get here.
然后我必须——我不知道——触摸她。我不知道。我不知道，抓她的屁股之类。然后，终于我们到了这里。
But it's not like that at all. It's less-- it's very-- I don't know. It varies. It's different from person to person. It could be anything. I don't know. Girls vary. Not every girl will like something that you do. Every girl is different.
但根本不是那样。它不那么——它是非常——我不知道。它会变。它因人而异。它可以是任何东西。我不知道。女孩们各不相同。不是每个女孩都会喜欢你做的事情。每个女孩都是不同的。
Everyone is different. Girls vary. People vary. What if that was the first thing you learned about sex?
每个人都是不同的。女孩们各不相同。人们各不相同。如果这是你关于性学到的第一件事会怎样？
What if instead of starting at 18 years old with rape and moving backwards to teach consent, what if you just started with people vary? Because if you understand that, consent follows. You have to ask questions and talk about what you like and don't like. Otherwise, you'll never know. You may be with one of those neck people, and you may not.
如果不是从18岁开始从强奸讲起，然后倒推来教同意，而是从“人们各不相同”开始呢？因为如果你理解了这一点，同意随之而来。你必须提出问题，谈论你喜欢什么和不喜欢什么。否则，你永远不会知道。你可能和那些脖子偏好者在一起，也可能不是。
For the rest of today's show, we are going to leave sex behind, and we are going to step forward from the beginning of life to the murky, complicated middle, the other facts of life that you really don't want to have to explain to children, because you wish they were not facts or a part of life at all. Our next story is from W. Kamau Bell. He's a comedian and a father.
在今天剩余的节目中，我们将告别性，我们将从生命的起点迈向模糊、复杂的中间地带，那些你真的不想不得不向孩子解释的生命的另一面，因为你希望它们根本不是事实或者生命的一部分。我们的下一个故事来自W. Kamau Bell。他是一位喜剧演员，也是一位父亲。
And recently, Kamau's been planning for a conversation he really does not want to have with his children, one that is familiar to black parents everywhere in America. Act Two, "If You See Racism, Say Racism." Here's Kamau.
最近，Kamau一直在为他真的不想和孩子们进行的对话做准备，这种对话对于美国各地的黑人父母来说都很熟悉。第二幕，《如果你看到种族主义，请说出来》。以下是Kamau。
I talk about race and racism in my act a lot, some would say too much. It was how I was raised. Some families have hardware stores. My family has thinking about racism. So it's no surprise to me that after I became a parent, I began to do jokes about race and racism and fatherhood.
我在我的表演中经常谈论种族和种族主义，有些人可能会说太多了。这就是我的成长方式。有些家庭有五金店。我的家庭有对种族主义的思考。所以在我成为父亲后，我开始创作关于种族、种族主义和父爱的笑话也就不足为奇了。
"And people ask me all the time, like, you're black. You talk about race a lot. And have you talked to your daughter about the fact that she's black? I'm like, no, because she's 3 and 1/2. I don't want to bum her out yet. You know what I'm saying?
“人们一直问我，你是个黑人。你经常谈论种族。你有没有和你的女儿谈过她是黑人这件事？我回答，没有，因为她才3岁半。我不想现在就让她沮丧。你明白我的意思吗？”
Being black is great, but it's like a big responsibility to know that. My mom waited until I was eight before she told me I was black. And she did it the right way.
作为黑人很棒，但这是一种知道这一点的巨大责任。我妈妈等到我八岁才告诉我我是黑人。而且她用了正确的方法。
One night she's like, tonight for dinner, you can have whatever you want. I was like, yay. And she's like, you can stay up all night and watch TV. I was like, yay. And you're black. I was like, hold on a second. That explains everything.
一天晚上她就像，今晚晚餐，你想吃什么都可以。我就像，耶。她就像，你可以整晚熬夜看电视。我就像，耶。而且你是黑人。我就像，等等。那解释了一切。
I thought every day I was just kind of having a shitty day. It's good to know why now. It's good to know there's a historical context for that."
我以为我每天都只是过得糟糕透顶。现在知道原因真是太好了。很高兴知道这背后有历史背景。
I now have two girls, a baby named Juno and an almost four-year-old named Sami. My wife, Melissa, is white. And Sami calls herself peanut butter. She really doesn't say much of anything yet.
我现在有两个女儿，一个叫Juno的婴儿和一个快四岁叫Sami的孩子。我的妻子Melissa是白人。Sami称自己为花生酱。她确实还没说什么。
My wife and I have both put our toes, or at least our older daughter, Sami's, toe in the race pool. But we have not even put the slightest hint of a Sami toe into the racism pool. Yes, those are separate pools.
我和我妻子都已经把脚趾，或者至少是我们大女儿Sami的脚趾，探入了种族之池。但我们甚至没有把哪怕一点点Sami的脚趾探入种族主义之池。是的，那是两个分开的池子。
The race pool is filled with positive stories of black achievement, African American role models, books and TV shows featuring diverse characters. Our race pool even has Kwanzaa.
种族之池里充满了黑人成就的积极故事、非裔美国人榜样、以多元化角色为特色的书籍和电视节目。我们的种族之池甚至还有宽扎节。
But Sami's racism pool is completely drained with a lock on the gate. And we run past it every day on the way to the race pool. And every day that goes by, I feel guilty. The racism pool is treacherous. It's not fun to swim in.
但Sami的种族主义之池完全干涸了，门上还锁着。我们每天去种族之池的路上都会经过它。每一天过去，我都感到内疚。种族主义之池是危险的。在里面游泳并不有趣。
And if you aren't careful, you drown in the sorrow of the black experience in America. Damn. We live in Berkeley. People have been protesting the police blocks from our house. How do I explain that?
而且如果你不小心，你会淹死在美国黑人经历的悲伤中。该死。我们住在伯克利。人们一直在我们家几个街区外抗议警察。我该怎么解释呢？
This was on my mind recently, how to teach Sami about racism, when this thing happened. It was January 26 of this year, my birthday. I was having a low key celebration, just like I like them.
这是我最近在思考的问题，如何向Sami解释种族主义，当时发生了那件事。那是今年的1月26日，我的生日。我正在进行低调的庆祝，就像我喜欢的那样。
I was carrying a children's book I had just bought for Sami, The Case for Loving: The Fight for Interracial Marriage. Mildred and Richard Loving are the interracial couple responsible for the Supreme Court striking down the laws in 16 states that banned interracial marriage. And if I was going to get into racism with Sami, then the Loving story-- which was about a family like ours-- seemed like a great place to start.
我拿着一本我刚为Sami买的儿童书，《爱的理由：争取跨种族婚姻的斗争》。Mildred和Richard Loving是一对跨种族夫妇，他们促使最高法院推翻了16个州禁止跨种族婚姻的法律。如果我要和Sami谈论种族主义，那么Loving的故事——关于一个像我们这样的家庭——似乎是一个很好的开始。
So I'm sure that many of you have heard the story of the incident that happened on January 26.
所以我相信你们很多人都听说过1月26日发生的那起事件的故事。
On a Friday in March, Melissa and I sat on a stage at a middle school in a packed auditorium. My main concern was that somehow all the planning and structure was going to lead to an event that was careful, sanitized, and maybe the worst thing, boring. It wasn't, due in large part to two amazing women on the panel, Kadijah Means-- who we'll get to in a minute-- but first, Nikki Jones.
在三月的一个周五，Melissa和我坐在中学礼堂的一个舞台上，台下坐满了人。我主要担心的是所有的计划和结构会导向一个小心翼翼、被消毒过，或许是最糟糕的——无聊的活动。但事实并非如此，这在很大程度上要归功于小组中的两位杰出女性，Kadijah Means——我们待会儿会谈到她——但首先是Nikki Jones。
OK. I'll put on my professor voice.
好的。我开启我的教授模式。
Nikki Jones teaches at UC Berkeley. She said something that, for me, made sense of the world, not just about the small racial injustices that happen in cafes but the bigger, deadly ones that are happening all around America. She asked us to think of the world in terms of black space and white space.
Nikki Jones在加州大学伯克利分校任教。她说了一些对我来说理清了这个世界，不仅是关于咖啡馆里发生的小种族不公，还有美国各地正在发生的更宏大、更致命的不公。她让我们从黑人空间和白人空间的角度去思考这个世界。
She credits Elijah Anderson for this theory, but tonight she made it her main point. Nikki says people have ideas about black spaces. It's tied to blackness and poverty and the ghetto. It's impossible to say the word ghetto in America without thinking about black people.
她将这个理论归功于Elijah Anderson，但今晚她把它作为重点。Nikki说人们对黑人空间有某种看法。它与黑人身份、贫困和贫民窟挂钩。在美国，不说贫民窟这个词而不想起黑人是不可能的。
See a black man in a suit, your brain does a calculus. What poor neighborhood did he or his parents rise up out of, or his parents' parents? It all goes back to the ghetto.
看到一个穿西装的黑人，你的大脑会进行计算。他或他的父母、他父母的父母是从哪个贫穷街区走出来的？这一切都回到了贫民窟。
And the ghetto itself is believed to be carried on the bodies, on and in black people. And that presents special dilemmas when black people are in white space. And what's white space? Well, just about everywhere else. Right?
而贫民窟本身被认为存在于身体上，存在于黑人的身上和内心。这在黑人处于白人空间时带来了特殊的困境。什么是白人空间？好吧，几乎所有其他地方。对吧？
She says UC Berkeley, where she teaches, white space. Almost all education, public and private, white space. Movie theaters, restaurants, some of my own stand-up shows-- I'm looking at you, Spokane-- white space. Public Radio, white space. And of course, the Elmwood cafe.
她说加州大学伯克利分校，她任教的地方，是白人空间。几乎所有的教育，公立和私立，都是白人空间。电影院、餐馆、我自己的一些单口喜剧表演——我看着你，斯波坎——白人空间。公共广播，白人空间。当然，还有Elmwood咖啡馆。
So in these white spaces, black people have a special burden, and they face a number of dilemmas. They have to prove that they belong there. The burden is on them to prove that they belong in a particular space.
所以在这些白人空间里，黑人背负着特殊的负担，他们面临着许多困境。他们必须证明自己属于那里。证明自己属于某个特定空间的重担在他们身上。
Now let's go back to the incident. Who belongs in that space? What is the presumption about what Kamau is carrying on his body?
现在回到那个事件。谁属于那个空间？关于Kamau身上背负着什么有什么假设？
Of course, not belonging can work both ways. A white person in a black space lacks a similar trustworthiness. But think of how rare it is that a white person goes to a black space. Like a tourist in another country, you can leave whenever you choose.
当然，不属于某种空间也可能双向运作。一个处于黑人空间的白人缺乏类似的可信度。但想想白人去黑人空间是多么罕见。就像在另一个国家的游客，你可以随时离开。
But the highlight of the night, high school senior, Kadijah Means. She's 18 and made a name for herself in the Bay Area as an activist. She's an awesome public speaker who, importantly to me, knows how to open with a joke.
但今晚的亮点是高中四年级学生，Kadijah Means。她18岁，在湾区作为活动家而出名。她是一位出色的演讲者，重要的是对我来说，她知道如何以笑话开场。
So number one, I want to say that I've been black all of my life. That's a pretty good amount of motivation for me to be a social justice advocate.
所以第一点，我想说我一辈子都是黑人。这是我成为社会正义倡导者的相当好的动力。
And then she said something that made me take extra notice. She talked about being younger than my daughter, Sami, when she learned about race.
然后她说了些让我格外注意的话。她谈到了在比我女儿Sami还小的时候就了解到了种族。
I learned about race at a really young age, maybe like two or three. My dad has a really good way of teaching about fractions. When he would make me toast, he would cut it in half and be like, this is half. This is a fourth.
我在很小的时候就了解了种族，也许两三岁左右。我爸爸有一个教分数的很好方法。当他给我做吐司时，他会把它切成两半，说，这是二分之一。这是四分之一。
So I learned about race in a kind of similar way, learning that white didn't mean white like paper, but it was a construct. Yeah, I learned that pretty young. That was weird.
所以我以类似的方式了解了种族，了解到白色并不意味着像纸那样的白色，而是一个建构。是的，我年纪很小就知道了。那很奇怪。
My oldest daughter is four. She has just begun to understand that people are different colors. I can't imagine somehow connecting that to the fact that race itself is a construct.
我的大女儿四岁。她刚刚开始理解人们的肤色不同。我无法想象将此与种族本身是一种建构这一事实联系起来。
I'm not sure I could define the word construct to another adult, let alone a four-year-old. Kadijah then closed with a few tips on how we can all be less racist, like this one.
我不确定我能否向另一个成年人定义“建构”这个词，更不用说四岁小孩了。Kadijah随后总结了几条关于我们如何才能减少种族主义的建议，比如这条。
Focus less on color blindness, because honestly, you're not going to get a gold star for that. Be more color competent. Be more--
少关注色盲，因为老实说，你不会因此得到金星。多一点颜色胜任力。多一点——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thanks.
谢谢。
And this one.
还有这条。
Please don't call people articulate. Don't come up to me after and tell me I'm articulate. Please do not do that. And there's a whole bunch of reasons why that we don't have time for.
请不要称人为“口齿伶俐”。不要在之后过来告诉我我很口齿伶俐。请不要那样做。这有很多原因，我们没有时间解释。
You might want to grab a pen and some paper, because she's on a roll.
你可能想拿支笔和纸，因为她正说得起劲。
Your mind makes generalizations. That's what it does. It's not bad to that. It's bad to think that that one generalization is what everyone is.
你的思想会做出概括。那就是它所做的。概括本身并不坏。坏的是认为那一个概括就是所有人。
You also have to take a step outside of that and remember that people are individuals. People have different lives. Just because I'm black doesn't mean I act like other black people. Black people built this country, whether you like it or not. Love us, please. Thank you.
你也必须从中走出来，记住人们是独立的个体。人们有不同的生活。仅仅因为我是黑人并不意味着我的行为像其他黑人。黑人建立了这个国家，不管你喜欢与否。请爱我们。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I was so impressed by Kadijah. I began to think about her dad, the one who taught her about fractions and race. Kadijah was completely versed in the evils of racism. But she was also idealistic about the future.
我对Kadijah印象深刻。我开始思考她的父亲，那个教她分数和种族的人。Kadijah对种族主义的罪恶非常精通。但她对未来也很理想化。
She understood how well-intended people could do racist things, but how that doesn't always make them bad people. She got the broad strokes and the nuances. And Kadijah also knew how to do something that is absolutely essential to your survival as a black person in America.
她理解善意的人如何可能做出种族主义行为，但这并不总是意味着他们是坏人。她把握了大局和细微差别。而且Kadijah也知道如何做一件对你在美国的黑人身份的生存至关重要的事情。
She saw and identified racism in her everyday life, and she didn't internalize it. But she also didn't ignore it. She just judo flipped it and kept walking. I wanted some advice on how to raise a kid like that. Who was this dad? I imagined him to be a mix of '60s era Berkeley hippie and hope and change era Obama.
她在日常生活中看到并识别出种族主义，她没有内化它。但她也没有忽视它。她只是像柔道一样将其翻转，然后继续前行。我想得到一些关于如何抚养那样一个孩子的建议。这位父亲是谁？我想象他是一个60年代伯克利嬉皮士和“希望与变革”时代奥巴马的混合体。
I don't smile a lot. So I'm not the smiling black man.
我不常笑。所以我不是那个爱笑的黑人。
Yeah. That's Cliff Means. He's a self-described businessman who means business.
是的。那是Cliff Means。他是一个自称“讲生意”的商人。
I like to imagine that his business card reads on one line, "Cliff Means," and under that, "Business." In fact, when we ask Cliff to do the interview, initially he said, "I don't know you. I don't know your audience. So no."
我喜欢想象他的名片上写着一行“Cliff Means”，下面写着“生意”。事实上，当我们请Cliff做采访时，起初他说，“我不认识你。我不了解你的听众。所以不行。”
So when my producer, Robyn, and I met with Cliff and Kadijah, I knew he was still reluctant, but I wasn't sure what had changed his mind. I had to ask.
所以当我的制作人Robyn和我与Cliff和Kadijah见面时，我知道他仍然很勉强，但我不知道是什么让他改变了主意。我不得不问。
Why are you doing this interview, then?
那为什么你要接受这次采访？
Kadijah really wanted me to do this is the bottom line. Now, had I found out anything too horrific about either one of you, then it probably still would have been no. But I couldn't find anything terrible.
Kadijah真的很希望我这样做，底线就是这样。现在，如果我发现你们俩中任何一个有什么太可怕的事情，那可能仍然会是拒绝。但我找不到任何糟糕的事情。
Well, I tell you, one thing that leaned in your favor. I did read something written by you, because I was trying to do as much homework as I could, because my answer was really no. And your writing had made enough white people angry that I said, OK, maybe he's actually trying to do something.
嗯，我告诉你，有一件事倾向于支持你们。我确实读过你写的东西，因为我在尽力做功课，因为我的答案最初真的是拒绝。你的文章让足够多的白人生气了，我说，好吧，也许他真的在试图做点什么。
So it's clear that Cliff is not exactly a "why can't we just get along" type of guy. And he has very clear thoughts about what should be taught to kids.
所以很明显，Cliff并不完全是那种“我们为什么不能和睦相处”类型的人。而且他对应该教给孩子的东西有非常明确的想法。
How old was Kadijah when you first started explaining race to her?
你第一次开始向Kadijah解释种族时她几岁？
I would imagine four or five years old. She was an early talker. We spent a ton of time together, because I asked her, does she want to enter a speech for the Martin Luther King celebration at her school. And we co-wrote a speech that people were very enamored with.
我想四五岁吧。她说话很早。我们花了很多时间在一起，因为我问她，她是否想为学校的马丁·路德·金庆祝活动准备一篇演讲。我们合写了一篇演讲，人们非常着迷。
And I explained to her that Martin Luther King wasn't killed for the "I Have a Dream" speech, but once he started talking about getting poor whites and poor blacks together, then he had to go. But my children, I taught, you will be going to school, and you will be getting told that there's justice for all. And then when you find out there's not, then you'll be confused. And I don't want my children confused. I want them knowledgeable.
我向她解释说，马丁·路德·金不是因为“我有一个梦想”的演讲而被杀的，而是当他开始谈论把贫穷的白人和贫穷的黑人联合起来时，他就必须消失。但我教我的孩子，你们会上学，你们会被告知人人平等。然后当你发现并不是那样时，你就会感到困惑。我不希望我的孩子困惑。我希望她们知识渊博。
So at what age did you get into the history of black people in this country and have to cover things like pre-Civil Rights Movement, like Jim Crow and slavery and things like that?
那么你在几岁时开始谈论这个国家的黑人历史，并且不得不涵盖像民权运动之前，像种族隔离和奴隶制之类的事情？
At five, I taught her about slavery, and I taught her as what it is, that Europe went to war with West Africa for centuries. Kids used to love Native Americans when I was a kid because they fought back. Why didn't black people fight back?
五岁时，我教她关于奴隶制的事，我如实告诉她，欧洲与西非交战了几个世纪。在我小时候，孩子们过去喜欢美洲原住民，因为他们反抗。为什么黑人不反抗？
Well, they did, and were slaughtered and terrorized and tortured and murdered and raped-- I probably left out rape at that age for her-- captured, kidnapped, and brought over Africans to America. And they were here terrorized and murdered. And we go from that stage all the way to being here, enslaved.
好吧，他们反抗了，然后被屠杀、恐吓、折磨、谋杀和强奸——那个年纪我可能对她略过了强奸——被俘虏、绑架，并被带到美国。他们在这里被恐吓和谋杀。我们从那个阶段一直谈到成为这里被奴役的人。
He taught her that at five. Cliff is clearly not afraid to throw his kids into the deep end of the racism pool and let them learn to swim. This is pretty much the opposite of what I had done so far. How deep did their racism pool get?
他五岁时就教了她这些。Cliff显然不怕把他的孩子扔进种族主义的深水区，让她们学会游泳。这和我目前所做的几乎相反。她们的种族主义之池有多深？
She learned things like white officers following the black migration to northern California to work in the shipping yards, in southern California was shipping yards. Hey, we'd better bring some racist white cops here to keep these people in line.
她学到了诸如白人警察跟踪黑人移民到北加州在船厂工作，南加州也有船厂。嘿，我们最好带些种族主义的白人警察来这里让这些人循规蹈矩。
She learned that there were black cooks grinding up glass in the kitchen to make sure that white racist, brutal slave masters' intestines would bleed and be open, and then he would be gone. What was your question?
她学到了有黑人厨师在厨房里磨碎玻璃，确保白人种族主义、残酷的奴隶主肠子会流血和裂开，然后他就消失了。你的问题是什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Do you want the church thing brought up at all?
你想提到教会那件事吗？
It's fine.
没关系。
That's Kadijah. I don't know what the church thing is, but I can tell it was one of those family stories. Kadijah let my producer, Robyn, and I in on it.
那是Kadijah。我不知道教会那件事是什么，但我能看出这是那些家庭故事之一。Kadijah让我和制作人Robyn知道了。
After my dad told me about racism, I distinctly remember being angry with white people, like how dare you enslave my people. And so we were at church one day.
在我爸爸告诉我关于种族主义的事后，我清楚地记得我对白人感到愤怒，就像你们怎么敢奴役我的人民。所以有一天我们在教堂。
It wasn't actually at church. It was a church function. It was in the church. It was a church function held after.
其实不是在教堂里。是在教堂举办的活动。是在教堂。那是事后举办的教堂活动。
So I guess I went up onto the pulpit and asked for the mic. And I told the entire congregation that black people and white people should not be together. And that was my synthesis of racism in America and slavery that I had come up with throughout the week after my dad told me about racism.
所以我猜我走上讲台要了麦克风。我告诉整个会众黑人和白人不应该在一起。这就是我从爸爸告诉我种族主义后的一周里总结出来的对美国种族主义和奴隶制的理解。
You're saying you became a five-year-old segregationist?
你是说你成了一个五岁的种族隔离主义者？
I did. I did.
是的。是的。
In my house, we can't have a five-year-old segregationist. I mean, don't get me wrong, it'd be fun for a bit in a Kids Say the Darndest Things kind of way. I ran a version of what Kadijah said in church by my wife, Melissa, as a hypothetical.
在我们家，我们不能有一个五岁的种族隔离主义者。我的意思是，别误会，以“小孩说最难听的话”这种方式看一会儿可能会很有趣。我把Kadijah在教堂说的那段话当作一个假设告诉了我妻子Melissa。
What would you do if Sami told you white people and black people can't be together? It would be an immediate investigation. Melissa would ask, "What makes you say that? Why do you think they can't be together? And yes, OK, white people did hurt your people. But also, Mommy and Daddy are together. And that's good, isn't it?"
如果你女儿Sami告诉你白人和黑人不能在一起，你会怎么做？那会是一场立即的调查。Melissa会问，“你为什么这么说？你为什么认为他们不能在一起？而且是的，好吧，白人确实伤害了你的人民。但妈妈和爸爸也在在一起。那很好，不是吗？”
It would be a conversation with me. It would be a conversation with Sami, every day, all the time. I asked Cliff how he felt about Kadijah's speech at church.
那会是我和她的对话。那会是我和Sami每天、一直在进行的对话。我问Cliff对Kadijah在教堂的演讲有什么感觉。
I was like, well, she learned what she learned. That's probably a healthy reaction for having learned what she learned this week. I think the audience was a little surprised.
我当时就像，好吧，她学到了她学到的。考虑到她这周学到的东西，这可能是一种健康的反应。我想观众有点惊讶。
Was there a white person in her life that you felt like, uh-oh, if she thinks that about all white people, then she's going to hate this one person who's actually, you know, a nice person?
她生活中是否有白人让你觉得，哦不，如果她那样看待所有白人，那她会恨这个实际上是好人的白人吗？
Oh, no, absolutely not. I'm not concerned about the white man in America. I think he's doing very well. And I had no concern, or do I now have any concern for anyone's feelings or whatever else being hurt by a five-year-old. Maybe it could start a conversation with them. They can think about some of the things that they enjoy that no one else enjoy in this country. So no.
哦，不，绝对没有。我不关心美国的白人。我认为他们做得很好。而且我没有，现在也没有任何关心任何人因为五岁小孩的话而感到受伤或无论什么。也许这可以开启他们之间的一个对话。他们可以思考一些他们享受而这个国家其他人没有享受的事情。所以不。
I really like Cliff. Cliff is not an easy person, but then why should he be easy? Cliff is the type of person who keeps the rest of us a little more honest. I want more Cliff in my life.
我真的很喜欢Cliff。Cliff不是一个容易相处的人，但话说回来，他为什么要容易呢？Cliff是那种让我们其余人保持更诚实的人。我的生活中需要更多像Cliff这样的人。
Kadijah told me that even with her candid, unfiltered upbringing, she could tell early on the difference between white oppression and the white people in her life. But to be able to do that, she had to learn about it and get angry. I get that.
Kadijah告诉我，即使在她那坦率、未经修饰的成长环境下，她也能很早就看出白人压迫与她生活中白人之间的区别。但要做到这一点，她必须去了解并感到愤怒。我明白这点。
When I first began to really understand the violence of racism, I was angry. It makes sense to be angry. The anger helps you push back against the injustice. Anger is not the goal. It's the fuel.
当我第一次真正开始理解种族主义的暴力时，我很愤怒。感到愤怒是合理的。愤怒帮助你抵制不公。愤怒不是目标。它是燃料。
Even so, sometimes I feel like I have too much anger. There are black people in America dying from racism. Bad treatment in a fancy coffee shop is the softest and easiest part of racism.
尽管如此，有时我觉得我有太多的愤怒。美国有黑人因种族主义而死亡。在高档咖啡馆里的恶劣待遇只是种族主义最温和、最容易的部分。
There were times during this whole thing I felt like I should just drop it. Cliff and I talked about that, too.
整个过程中有几次我觉得我应该放弃。Cliff和我也谈过这一点。
Being told to leave a cafe on College Avenue, that's not a big deal on a basic level. But I knew that you can't just keep letting your boundary get pushed.
被告知离开大学大道的咖啡馆，在基本层面上不是什么大不了的事。但我知道你不能一直让你的界限被推开。
I don't let anything go. I don't let anything go. Don't shake my hand like you're black or something. You shake my hand like a white man. You shake my hand like you shake-- don't relate to me.
我什么都不放过。我什么都不放过。不要像你是黑人一样跟我握手。你要像白人一样跟我握手。你要像——不要跟我建立关联。
Don't let anything go is the message of the day. That's what I feel, but I never put it in those words. Those are the words I was looking for. Don't let anything go.
“什么都不放过”是今天的讯息。这就是我的感受，但我从没用这些词表达过。那是我一直在寻找的词。什么都不放过。
Racism is real and happening right now, every day. That means that every day I have an opportunity to teach my daughters about racism. So this is to you, Sami and Juno. I promise you, from now on, I'm not going to let it go. The stakes are too high.
种族主义是真实的，每天都在发生。这意味着每一天我都有机会教我的女儿们关于种族主义的事。所以这是对你们说的，Sami和Juno。我向你们保证，从现在开始，我绝不放过。赌注太大了。
W. Kamau Bell is a comedian in Berkeley. You can hear him on his podcast, "Denzel Washington is the Greatest Actor of All Time Period," or find a list of his upcoming shows on his website, wkamaubell.com. That's W-K-A-M-A-U Bell dot com.
W. Kamau Bell是伯克利的喜剧演员。你可以在他的播客《丹泽尔·华盛顿是史上最伟大的演员》中听到他，或者在他的网站wkamaubell.com上找到他即将举行的演出列表。即W-K-A-M-A-U Bell点com。
Coming up, a group of grownups who are not fumbling at all. They have a plan, and it includes costumes, volcanoes, and a talking stick. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一群完全没有笨拙的成年人。他们有一个计划，包括戏服、火山和谈话棒。一分钟后，当我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续时，你就会知道了。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Birds and the Bees." We are listening in as grownups try to convey their most important deeply-held beliefs to small humans who cannot yet zip up their own jackets.
这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今天的节目是《鸟儿与蜜蜂》。我们正在聆听成年人试图向还不会自己拉上夹克拉链的小人类传达他们最重要的核心信念。
We started at the beginning, where do babies come from? In this last part of the show, we're going to talk about the end. Act Three, "About That Farm Upstate." Jonathan Goldstein has this last story.
我们从头开始，婴儿来自哪里？在节目的最后一部分，我们将谈论结束。第三幕，《关于北部的那个农场》。Jonathan Goldstein有最后一个故事。
And a quick warning, like I said at the beginning of the show, these are stories about grownups talking with children about difficult subject matter. So if you have kids with you, keep that in mind. OK, here's Jonathan.
顺便提醒一下，就像我在节目开头所说，这些是关于成年人与孩子谈论困难主题的故事。所以如果你身边有孩子，请记住这一点。好的，这是Jonathan的故事。
There's a house in Salt Lake City where kids come to have death explained to them, not just that people die but how they die. It's called The Sharing Place. And the first person they meet there is Jill Macfarlane. This is how she explains a heart attack.
在盐湖城有一所房子，孩子们到那里去听关于死亡的解释，不仅是人会死，还有他们是如何死的。它叫The Sharing Place。他们在那里见到的第一个人是Jill Macfarlane。这就是她解释心脏病发作的方式。
Your heart stopped working, and it couldn't move your blood through your body.
你的心脏停止工作了，它无法再将血液泵送到全身。
She has a quiver full of kid-sized explanations for all the ways that life can end, like kidney failure.
她有一大堆适合孩子的解释，说明生命终结的各种方式，比如肾衰竭。
Your kidneys are washing machines for your blood. And when they stop working and your blood's dirty, then it poisons your body, and you die.
你的肾脏是血液的洗衣机。当它们停止工作而你的血液变脏时，它会毒害你的身体，然后你就死了。
Overdoses.
药物过量。
Overdose is when you have a sickness in your brain called addiction. An addiction makes you take medicine that's not good for you, and you take way too much of it. But not all medicine's bad either.
药物过量是指你的大脑患有一种叫成瘾的疾病。成瘾会让你服用对你身体不好的药物，而你服用了太多。但也不是所有药物都坏。
Have you dealt with murder?
你处理过谋杀案吗？
Mm-hm. It's when somebody chooses to make your body stop working. It's a choice. We also do choice and not choice. Like, murder is a choice. Cancer is not a choice.
嗯，有。那是有人选择让你的身体停止工作。这是一种选择。我们也谈论选择和非选择。比如，谋杀是一种选择。癌症不是选择。
We also do contagious or not contagious. Like, you're not going to get my depression. And you're not going to get my cancer.
我们也谈论传染或不传染。比如，你不会得我的抑郁症。你也不会得我的癌症。
The Sharing Place is a grief support center for kids who have lost a family member. It's one of hundreds of centers like it around the country. Kids sit in support groups led by grownups, but the point is to allow children to talk to other children about their grief.
The Sharing Place是一个为失去家庭成员的孩子提供的悲伤支持中心。它是全国数百个此类中心之一。孩子们坐在由成年人领导的支持小组中，但目的是让孩子们能够与其他孩子谈论他们的悲伤。
They're encouraged to speak in concrete language about death because, the thinking goes, that's how to process death's finality. So people don't pass away. You don't lose them. They die.
他们被鼓励用具体的语言谈论死亡，因为人们认为，这就是处理死亡不可逆性的方式。所以人们不会“离世”。你不会“失去”他们。他们死了。
We invest so much effort trying to shield kids from the scary things in life. We place advisories before TV shows that warn against inappropriate language and subject matter. And what could be less appropriate than death?
我们投入了如此大的努力试图保护孩子免受生活中可怕事物的伤害。我们在电视节目之前放置建议，警告不适当的语言和主题。有什么比死亡更不适当的吗？
So for all we let on-- bunnies lay eggs. Your mother means well. And life pretty much goes on forever. To do otherwise feels like you're breaking a basic pact that grownups have with one another.
所以尽管我们放任——兔子会下蛋。你母亲是为你好。生命几乎永远继续。做其他的事感觉就像你打破了成年人之间的一项基本契约。
Who did you have die?
谁死了？
My dad, two guinea pigs, a dog, two cats, and my dad. And that's all.
我的爸爸，两只豚鼠，一只狗，两只猫，还有我的爸爸。就这样。
The kids here are more comfortable talking about death than most adults are, like Hailey, who lost a sister and brother to mitochondrial disease. She and her other brother have the disease, too, but not as bad. They've had to deal with something that most other people haven't had too, let alone other kids. So it's hard to talk about with the kids at school.
这里的孩子比大多数成年人更乐于谈论死亡，比如Hailey，她因线粒体疾病失去了一个姐姐和一个哥哥。她和她另一个哥哥也患有这种病，只是没那么严重。他们不得不面对大多数人甚至其他孩子从未遇到过的事情。所以很难与学校的孩子们谈论。
Sometimes they don't even know what we're talking about, because we know all this stuff, like all these words that none of the other kids heard about, like neurological or something like that. And they're like, what does that mean? Or like a feeding tube, what does that mean?
有时他们甚至不知道我们在谈论什么，因为我们知道所有这些东西，比如所有其他孩子没听说过的词，比如“神经系统”之类的。他们就会说，那是什么意思？或者像喂食管，那是什么意思？
It's like really hard to explain.
这真的很难解释。
It's not hard to explain, but it's hard to tell them, and they still don't understand where it goes or what it does to help you.
不是很难解释，但很难告诉他们，而且他们仍然不明白它去哪里或者它是如何帮助你的。
But this is a place where kids do understand. There are more than a dozen separate the groups at The Sharing Place, broken down by age. The groups meet twice a month for about an hour and a half in a refurbished house, made to feel homey and safe so it's like visiting your grandma's.
但这是一个孩子们确实能理解的地方。The Sharing Place有十几组独立的小组，按年龄划分。小组每两周在房子里开会一次，大约一个半小时，房子经过翻新，让人感到舒适安全，就像去奶奶家一样。
There are rooms where kids meet and talk and rooms where their parents do the same. But most of the rooms are dedicated to play. There's a costume room where kids can dress up like police, ballerinas, cowboys.
有房间供孩子们见面聊天，也有房间供他们的父母做同样的事。但大多数房间致力于游戏。有一个戏服室，孩子们可以打扮成警察、芭蕾舞演员、牛仔。
I'm Spider-Man. So you can do whatever I tell you to do.
我是蜘蛛侠。所以你可以做我告诉你的任何事。
And beside it is a room called the soft room, which is full of props and toys, including an old telephone. One little girl who watched her mother have a heart attack spent an entire play session pretending to call for help.
旁边是一个叫“软软屋”的房间，里面充满了道具和玩具，包括一部旧电话。一个小女孩目睹了她母亲心脏病发作，她花了一整段游戏时间假装拨打求救电话。
"Hi, 9-1-1," she'd say. "My grandma's dying. Hurry. Come quick." Then she'd hang up and dial again. "Hi, 9-1-1, my dad's dying. Hurry. Come quick."
“你好，911，”她说。“我奶奶快不行了。快点。快过来。”然后她会挂断电话再次拨打。“你好，911，我爸爸快不行了。快点。快过来。”
One of the most popular rooms is a padded room called the volcano room.
最受欢迎的房间之一是一个叫“火山房”的软垫房间。
I'm going to go play in the volcano room.
我要去火山房玩。
It's full of cushions and large rubber yoga balls. It's even got an adult-sized dummy to wrestle and punch. The kids can scream, yell, pound the walls, and throw things around. They love it.
里面满是靠垫和大的橡胶瑜伽球。它甚至有一个成人大小的假人供人摔打和猛击。孩子们可以尖叫、大喊、捶墙、到处扔东西。他们很喜欢。
Whoo. Bling. Boom. Bam. No ball can attack me. Whoo! Boing.
呜。砰。蹦。砸。没有球能攻击我。呜！蹦。
It's a release. Eve is nine years old, and her father died about two years ago. She knows that feeling of keeping it all bottled up inside. She says she can go days at school like that.
这是一种释放。Eve九岁了，她父亲大约两年前去世。她知道那种把一切都憋在心里的感觉。她说她可以在学校那样过几天。
It kind of feels really overwhelming. And it's like you don't know what to do. And on the inside, it's like hurting somehow in a feeling way. It like hurts somehow.
感觉真的很有压力。就像你不知道该怎么办。而在内心深处，就像以某种感觉的方式受到伤害。它确实以某种方式受伤。
Where would you say it hurts?
你会说它哪里受伤了？
Usually, with me, it would hurt in the throat and kind of in my stomach. It's like something that needs to come out, but just I really need to learn how to do that.
通常，对我来说，它会在喉咙和胃部受伤。就像有什么东西需要出来，但我真的需要学习如何做到这一点。
I think there are people in this world who can grow up and don't really know how to talk frankly about lots of things.
我想世界上有些人可以长大，却真的不知道如何坦率地谈论很多事情。
Nancy Reiser is one of the co-founders of The Sharing Place. And this is what she says when children ask her how people die.
Nancy Reiser是The Sharing Place的联合创始人之一。当孩子们问她人们是如何死亡时，她就是这样说的。
I say, well, close your eyes and listen. [HEAVY BREATHING]
我说，嗯，闭上眼睛听着。[沉重的呼吸声]
And there isn't the next breath. Does it hurt? I don't think so. I don't think so. Their face doesn't look like it hurt.
然后就没有下一次呼吸了。它痛吗？我不这么认为。我不这么认为。他们的脸看起来不像很痛。
Nancy's a therapist who works with young children. For a long time, the very concept that children do, in fact, grieve was hotly disputed. Freud said that it was difficult for children to even conceive of such loss. And as a culture, Nancy says, that's pretty much the idea that we operate under.
Nancy是一位与幼儿合作的治疗师。很长一段时间里，孩子们确实会悲伤这一概念一直存在激烈争议。弗洛伊德说，孩子甚至很难构想出这样的损失。作为一个文化，Nancy说，这几乎就是我们运作的基础理念。
Oh, look, she's playing. She's OK. She didn't really understand what happened. Well, she's playing. But then half an hour later, she's in the house, holding her teddy bear and sucking her thumb and crying.
哦，看，她在玩耍。她很好。她并没有真正理解发生了什么。但半小时后，她在房子里，抱着她的泰迪熊，吮吸着手指，哭泣。
So we need to let people know that children grieve, and help them when they grieve so it's not stuck inside and comes out when they try to have a relationship later. When they start to get intimate, they cannot bear it, and they go off. And they don't know why.
所以我们需要让人们知道孩子们会悲伤，并在他们悲伤时帮助他们，这样悲伤就不会困在心里，导致他们在以后建立关系时爆发。当他们开始亲密时，他们无法承受，然后他们就离开了。而他们不知道为什么。
Nancy says children just grieve differently than adults, especially little children. They grieve in fits and starts. They can't focus on it for very long. And grief is more physical for them.
Nancy说孩子们的悲伤方式与成年人不同，尤其是幼儿。他们的悲伤是断断续续的。他们无法长时间专注。而且对他们来说，悲伤更具身体性。
They'll act out their anger, maybe kick a door, which is the reason for the volcano room at The Sharing Place. They might also regress, suddenly using baby talk or sucking their thumbs. And if they're potty trained, they might become untrained.
他们会发泄愤怒，也许踢门，这就是The Sharing Place有火山房的原因。他们也可能退化，突然使用婴儿语或吮吸手指。如果他们已经戒了尿布，他们可能会重新尿床。
They're also magical thinkers. I heard stories of kids who were afraid to go to sleep because grandma went to sleep and didn't wake up. One little boy wandered away from his mom at the emergency room saying, I'm looking for Dad. We left him here last time. Another boy said he just wanted to die for a few days so he can go to heaven and teach his little sister how to ride a tricycle.
他们也是魔法思维者。我听说过孩子们害怕睡觉的故事，因为奶奶睡着了就没醒来。一个小男孩在急诊室从他妈妈身边走开说，我在找爸爸。上次我们把他留在这里了。另一个男孩说他只想死几天，这样他就能去天堂教他妹妹骑三轮车了。
Children also re-grieve. That is, with every new stage of development, they experience their grief anew. And with every milestone-- when their braces come off, when they get their driver's license, when they graduate-- they'll inevitably think, I wish my mom was here.
孩子们也会重新悲伤。也就是说，随着每个新的发展阶段，他们会重新体验他们的悲伤。随着每一个里程碑——当他们的牙套拆掉时，当他们拿到驾照时，当他们毕业时——他们不可避免地会想，我希望我妈妈在这里。
And given all of this, the thought behind The Sharing Place and other centers like it is that kids can help one another in a way that adults perhaps can't help them. That's why they're brought together in these groups. In short, kids speak the same language.
鉴于所有这些，The Sharing Place及其他中心背后的想法是，孩子们可以以一种成年人可能无法帮助他们的方式互相帮助。这就是为什么他们被聚在一起的原因。简而言之，孩子说同样的语言。
Is that thing turned on?
那个东西开着吗？
It is turned on. What do you think about that?
开着。你怎么看？
Before their session at The Sharing Place, I sit down with Gavin, who's six, and his brother, Aidan, who's eight. They're both dressed in matching long-sleeved polo shirts. Gavin sits on his mother Nichole's lap. Aidan sits beside them.
在他们参加The Sharing Place的会议之前，我和六岁的Gavin以及他八岁的哥哥Aidan坐在一起。他们都穿着配套的长袖Polo衫。Gavin坐在他妈妈Nichole的腿上。Aidan坐在他们旁边。
Oh, do you want to introduce yourself?
哦，你想自我介绍一下吗？
Hi. I'm Aidan. My dad died by--
嗨。我是Aidan。我爸爸死于——
Suicide.
自杀。
His little brother, Gavin, points his finger to his head and pulls the pretend trigger. He snaps is head back.
他弟弟Gavin把手指指向自己的头，扣动了假想的扳机。他头向后一仰。
Yep, that's what happened.
是的，那就是发生的。
What did you just do there?
你刚才做了什么？
He shot his head. And then, we didn't know he was dead, right Mama?
他射了自己的头。然后，我们不知道他死了，对吧妈妈？
We didn't.
我们不知道。
And then we said, "Wake up, Dad."
然后我们说，“醒醒，爸爸。”
No, you didn't see him. Mommy found him. And he was already dead.
不，你们没看见他。妈妈发现了他。他已经死了。
Did you turn him over?
你把他翻过来了吗？
I didn't touch him.
我没碰他。
OK.
好的。
Because she knew he was dead, because she saw blood and things.
因为她知道他死了，因为她看到了血之类的东西。
On his head?
在他头上？
Yeah. And he was a terrific guy-- so nice, so generous. He would always help anyone. He was a terrific guy.
是的。他是个了不起的人——非常善良，非常慷慨。他总是乐于助人。他是个了不起的人。
What did you learn here that helped you the most?
你在这里学到的哪一点对你帮助最大？
To understand how he died.
理解他是怎么死的。
Sometimes that task, telling the kids that their parent committed suicide, falls to Jill Macfarlane, because the surviving parent or guardian might be so inside their own grief that they can't bring themselves to do it. Jill explains suicide as simply as she does other kinds of death.
有时这项任务，告诉孩子他们的父母自杀了，落在了Jill Macfarlane身上，因为幸存的父母或监护人可能深陷自己的悲伤中，无法开口。Jill解释自杀的方式和解释其他死亡方式一样简单。
There's a sickness in your brain called depression, she says. And it can make you decide to make your own body stop working. She says it's required that the kids know how their brother or sister or mother died before starting the group.
你的大脑患有一种叫抑郁症的疾病，她说。它能让你决定让自己的身体停止工作。她说，在开始小组活动之前，要求孩子们知道他们的兄弟姐妹或母亲是如何死亡的。
Well, I had one family say he died because he was sick. One family said that he died in a car accident. One family said that he accidentally shot himself. He didn't mean to.
嗯，有一个家庭说他因为生病去世了。一个家庭说他在车祸中丧生。一个家庭说他不小心射中自己。他不是故意的。
It was Jill who helped their mom break the news to Aidan and Gavin that their dad shot himself. She says that conversation was especially hard.
是Jill帮助他们的母亲把他们父亲开枪自杀的消息告诉了Aidan和Gavin。她说那次谈话特别困难。
The boys immediately said, you don't know my dad. Why would you say that? You don't know us.
男孩们立即说，你不认识我爸爸。你为什么这么说？你不认识我们。
And I said, I know. I don't know you. But your mom's here today because she needed my help in telling you this, because this is a really hard and scary thing that happened. And your mom told me that that's what happened.
我说，我知道。我不认识你们。但你妈妈今天在这儿，因为她需要我的帮助来告诉你们这件事，因为这是一个非常困难和可怕的事情。你妈妈告诉我那是发生的。
And Aidan just was like, you're crazy, lady. There's no way that we're going to talk about this. This is not what happened. It was horrible and was awful. And I cried that whole night.
Aidan就像，你疯了，女士。我们不可能谈论这个。这不是发生的。那是可怕的，那是糟糕的。我那天晚上哭了一整夜。
It was just awful. I just felt so horrible. And my husband was like, you can't do this. You have to go to the director and tell her that you can't do this again.
那真的太糟糕了。我感到太可怕了。我丈夫就像，你不能这样做。你必须去告诉主任你不能再这样做了。
Suicide is always one of the highest, if not the highest cause of death for Sharing Place families at any given time. There's actually a special group devoted specifically to suicide.
无论何时，自杀始终是The Sharing Place家庭死亡的主要原因，如果不是主要原因的话。实际上有一个专门针对自杀的特殊小组。
And a lot of the stories you hear in that group are so horrible that you can't help but wonder, why tell the kids what happened at all? Why not just say they died and leave it at that?
你在那个小组里听到的很多故事都太可怕了，你忍不住想，为什么要告诉孩子发生了什么？为什么不只是说他们死了然后就此打住呢？
According to Jill and her colleagues, we need to tell children so they won't find out later in life and wonder, what else did they lie to me about? They also don't want to have to cloak it in a way that suggests it's unspeakable and shameful. They get enough of that idea at school.
根据Jill和她同事的说法，我们需要告诉孩子们，这样他们长大后就不会发现真相并想，他们还对我撒了什么谎？他们也不想以一种暗示这是不可言说且令人羞耻的方式来掩盖它。他们在学校里已经受够了那种想法。
This is Eve again, whose father also shot himself.
这是Eve，她父亲也是开枪自杀的。
Well, some people at school, they say this makes me feel really sad, too. They say that when somebody kills themselves, that means they go to the wrong place. I don't believe that, but it just makes me feel really sad when they say that. Like instead of going to a happy place, they would go to a sad.
嗯，学校里有些人，他们说这让我感觉很难过。他们说当有人自杀时，那意味着他们去了错误的地方。我不相信，但当他们那样说时，确实让我感觉很难过。就像他们没去一个快乐的地方，而是去了一个悲伤的地方。
But even if you don't believe it, and you know it's nonsense, it still kind of hurts that someone would say that?
但即使你不相信，而且你知道那是无稽之谈，有人那样说还是会让人受伤？
Yeah, it does, because it's like somebody judging my papa, which it's not a bad thing. A lot of people do that. But you know, just kind of feels a little weird. Like on the inside, it makes me feel like I'm going to scream and do something like that.
是的，确实会，因为就像有人在评判我爸爸，那不是一件坏事。很多人都那样做。但你知道，感觉有点怪怪的。在内心深处，让我感觉我想尖叫，想做那样的事情。
What are the things that you wish that people would say?
你希望人们说什么？
Probably it's OK that that has happened. And we can help you with feeling better and understanding you. That's probably something I'd want somebody to say.
可能就是，发生了那样的事没关系。我们可以帮助你感觉更好并理解你。那可能是我希望有人说的。
Once a child knows how their loved one died, they're encouraged to say it out loud. There's a kind of sorcery to it, naming the dragon so you can defeat it.
一旦孩子知道他们心爱的人是如何死亡的，他们就被鼓励大声说出来。这有一种魔法，命名那条龙，这样你就能击败它。
I sat in on the suicide group, which is different than the other groups in that kids tend to come to meetings for a longer period of time, partly because they didn't get to say goodbye. The kids sit a circle at the beginning of the meeting and hand around a talking stick. One by one, they say their name, who died, and how they died.
我参加了自杀小组，这与其他小组不同，孩子们往往会参加更长时间的会议，部分原因是他们没能说再见。孩子们在会议开始时围成一个圈，传递一个谈话棒。一个接一个，他们说出自己的名字，谁死了，以及他们是怎么死的。
My name is Elias, and the person who died was my dad. And he died by shooting his self with a gun. And he wanted to die.
我叫Elias，死的人是我爸爸。他用枪射击自己死了。而且他想死。
Hello, my name is Lindsey. My dad died. He died by suicide. And I regret not seeing him, because I hadn't seen him for a couple of months before his death.
你好，我叫Lindsey。我爸爸死了。他是自杀的。我后悔没见到他，因为在他去世前几个月我没见过他。
There's also a different question they respond to each time they meet. What do you miss most about the person? Is there anything you don't miss? Tonight's question is, what do you regret?
他们每次聚会时回答的问题也不一样。你最怀念那个人的什么？有什么你不怀念的吗？今晚的问题是，你后悔什么？
My name is Ethan, and the person who died is my dad. He died by shooting his self in the head. And I don't know if I have any regrets. I just can't remember.
我叫Ethan，死的人是我爸爸。他朝自己脑袋开枪死了。我不知道我有没有什么遗憾。我只是记不起来了。
It can take a long time for them to get to this point, where they can say the word suicide. The Sharing Place never corrects any of the kids or forces them to say anything they don't want to. But they notice when a child is finally able to say it.
他们可能需要很长时间才能达到这一点，能够说出“自杀”这个词。The Sharing Place从不纠正任何孩子或强迫他们说任何他们不想说的话。但他们会注意到一个孩子终于能说出来的时候。
The night I was there, Aidan, the nine-year-old I talked to who had a hard time saying the word suicide, was finally able to say it in group.
我在的那晚，Aidan，那个我交谈过的九岁孩子，他很难说出“自杀”这个词，终于能在小组里说出来了。
So how about Aidan?
那么Aidan怎么样？
The volunteers sat around and talked about it afterwards.
志愿者们围坐在一起事后讨论。
It was hard for him, I could tell. He wasn't about to say it, but he said it. And I was proud of him. But it took him probably at least a minute to actually get those words out.
对他来说很难，我看得出来。他本来不想说，但他说了。我为他感到骄傲。但他可能至少花了一分钟才真正把那些词说出来。
And he had to ask his mom if it was OK to say.
而且他必须问他妈妈说出来是否可以。
So she wasn't coaching him?
所以她没有在指导他？
Nope.
没有。
No. He was good.
不。他表现得很好。
On the other hand, Aidan's brother, Gavin, the six-year-old, talks about his dad's suicide incessantly. He also draws guns during playtime and even sculpts them out of Play-Doh. This is Jill Macfarlane again.
另一方面，Aidan的弟弟Gavin，那个六岁的孩子，不停地谈论他爸爸的自杀。他在玩耍时也画枪，甚至用橡皮泥雕塑枪。这是Jill Macfarlane。
He tells everybody at school, "My dad shot his brains." And it freaks everybody out. And so then he gets in trouble at school, which then he was like, well, I guess I can't ever talk about my dad.
他告诉学校里的每个人，“我爸爸射了自己的大脑。”这让每个人都吓坏了。所以他在学校惹了麻烦，然后他就像，好吧，我想我永远不能谈论我爸爸了。
But this is how kindergartners talk and process things. It's just easy for them to talk about. But it scares other people.
但这正是幼儿园孩子说话和处理事情的方式。对他们来说谈论这些很容易。但这会吓到其他人。
Is it OK for other kids in their class to hear that kind of thing?
班上的其他孩子听到那种话没关系吗？
Well, yeah. I mean, is there a right answer to that? I don't know.
嗯，是的。我的意思是，有正确的答案吗？我不知道。
I don't know either. If I were a parent, I'm not sure I'd want my kid hearing that kind of thing at school. And while Jill doesn't have an answer, she does think kids being allowed to express themselves is much healthier than sending them a message that it's wrong to say this kind of stuff out loud. And that's got to be a step in the right direction.
我也不知道。如果我是父母，我不确定我是否想让我的孩子在学校听到那种话。虽然Jill没有答案，但她确实认为，允许孩子表达自己远比向他们传达“说出这类话是错误的”这种信息要健康得多。那一定是朝着正确方向迈出的一步。
I have very, very, very fond memories of this place. I actually tried to come through the side door, because that was the door that I always came in through. Then I was like, I can use the adult entrance, finally.
我对这个地方有非常、非常、非常美好的回忆。我实际上试着从侧门进来，因为那是我总是进来的门。然后我心想，我终于可以使用成人入口了。
Sara Mohammed hasn't been to The Sharing Place for a full six years. She's 21 now. But when she was 11, her older brother hanged himself.
Sara Mohammed已经六年没来过The Sharing Place了。她现在21岁了。但当她11岁时，她哥哥上吊自杀了。
Even though he was supposed to be babysitting her, her parents had told her to keep an eye out on him because of his past suicide attempts. Obviously what happened wasn't her fault, but she blamed herself, which is something I heard other kids here talk about too.
尽管他本应照顾她，但她父母告诉她要留意他，因为他有过自杀倾向。显然发生的事不是她的错，但她责怪自己，这是我听到其他孩子也谈论的事情。
It's easy for an adult to say, don't be silly. It's not your fault. But it's a whole other thing to talk with a kid at The Sharing Place who says, I know exactly what you're talking about.
成年人说“别傻了，这不是你的错”很容易。但与在The Sharing Place中说“我完全明白你在说什么”的孩子交谈是另一回事。
It was kind of nice seeing the older kids whose loved ones had been gone for a few years, how they were able to go to school normally and just live their normal lives, because I just didn't want to go to school. I didn't want to be with kids who just didn't know. It was too hard.
看到那些心爱的人已经离开几年的大孩子能够像正常人一样上学并过正常生活，感觉很好，因为我当时根本不想上学。我不想和那些什么都不知道的孩子在一起。太难了。
I asked Sara if there was a turning point, a moment when she began to feel like maybe she was doing a little better. She said, yes. She was in the courtyard with a bunch of other kids.
我问Sara是否有转折点，那一刻她开始觉得也许她好转了一点。她说，是的。她和一群其他孩子在庭院里。
We were just out there painting rocks or something for a fundraiser. And we were just talking, just talking like normal. And I realized that I hadn't had a conversation like that in about a year, just where I felt 100% free, and just laughing and not feeling guilty about laughing, and just happy. And yeah, that was really the first time in a good nine months after my brother had passed that I felt OK.
我们只是在那里画石头之类为筹款做准备。我们只是在谈话，就像正常人一样谈话。我意识到我大约一年没进行过那样的谈话了，就是我觉得百分之百自由，只是大笑而不会因为大笑感到内疚，只是快乐。是的，那确实是我哥哥去世后九个月里第一次感觉还好。
It's the kids themselves who decide when they're ready to stop coming to The Sharing Place. But on average, they stay about two years. When they're ready to leave, they have to announce their intention two times in group before their final goodbye.
是孩子们自己决定什么时候准备停止来The Sharing Place。但平均来说，他们待大约两年。当他们准备离开时，他们在小组里必须宣布两次他们的意图，然后才能进行最后的告别。
Any of you that would like to say something to him, which I'm sure several of you will?
你们中有谁想对他说话吗，我肯定你们中很多人都会？
The goodbye is ceremonial. And on the last night I was there, at the end of the meeting, they said goodbye to a kid name Robby. He sat in the circle with the other kids and volunteers. And anybody who wanted to could pick up the talking stick and say a few words. His friend, Jessica, was the last kid to do so.
告别是仪式性的。我在那里的最后一个晚上，会议结束时，他们向一个叫Robby的孩子道别。他和其他孩子及志愿者坐在圈子里。任何想说话的人都可以拿起谈话棒说几句。他的朋友Jessica是最后一个这么做的孩子。
I'll definitely miss you, because you're like one of my best friends in this group. And I'll miss seeing you. And our major fight that we had in the volcano room, it was not my fault.
我一定会想念你的，因为你就像我在这个小组里最好的朋友之一。我会想念看到你的。我们在火山房打的那场大架，那不是我的错。
You asked for it.
是你自找的。
No I didn't.
不，我没。
Yes, you did.
是的，你有。
No. It was just really fun, and I'm going to miss seeing you and miss hanging out with you.
不。那真的很有趣，我会想念你的，想念和你一起玩。
At Robby's last meeting, there was a kid who'd just shown up. It was his first meeting. He had long bangs hanging over his eyes and, except for his name, didn't say anything the whole time.
在Robby最后一次会议上，有一个刚来的孩子。这是他第一次来。他长长的刘海垂在眼睛上，除了名字，他整个过程中一句话也没说。
Whenever a new person joins, the veteran kids have a chance to gauge their own progress, to remember what they were like when they first showed up, and think about how bad it used to be, and how now it isn't as bad. And ultimately, like Robby, they'll make way for someone on the long waiting list, a list on which new names are added all the time. They'll say, "I think it's time to go." And then they'll say it again.
每当有新人加入，老学员们就有机会衡量自己的进步，记住他们刚到时是什么样子，思考过去有多糟，而现在没那么糟了。最终，就像Robby一样，他们会给漫长的等待名单上的人腾出空间，那是一份名单，新的名字一直都在增加。他们会说，“我想是时候走了。”然后他们会再说一次。
Jonathan Goldstein is host of the CBC radio show and podcast, Wiretap.
Jonathan Goldstein是CBC电台节目和播客《Wiretap》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "TEACH THE GIFTED CHLIDREN," BY LOU REED]
[音乐 - Lou Reed的《TEACH THE GIFTED CHILDREN》]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Ira Glass, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder.
我们的节目今天由Robyn Semien与Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Ira Glass, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike共同制作。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。
Editing help from Joel Lovell, production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
编辑帮助来自Joel Lovell，制作帮助来自Simon Adler。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的办公室经理。Elna Baker为我们的节目搜寻故事。Michelle Harris和Christopher Swetala提供了研究帮助。Damien Graef和Rob Geddis提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, The Public Radio Exchange. Thanks today to my boss, Ira Glass, who was very gracious in handing over today's show, at first. But then, in the last day or so, I think he's a little bored or something. He keeps popping his head in randomly.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）送达公共广播电台。感谢今天的老板Ira Glass，他非常大度地交出了今天的节目，起初是这样。但后来，在过去这一两天里，我想他有点无聊之类。他一直在随机地探出头来。
I'm Spider-Man. So you can do whatever I tell you to do.
我是蜘蛛侠。所以你可以做我告诉你的任何事。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "TEACH THE GIFTED CHLIDREN," BY LOU REED]
[音乐 - Lou Reed的《TEACH THE GIFTED CHILDREN》]